jo leute bevor das video losgeht wo ich
noch kurz fragen und zwar habe ich
vorher im dezember als vom ersten bis
zum letzten dezember jeden tag ein video
rauszuhauen natürlich ist das für mich
ziemlich stressig jeden tag ein video zu
machen aber es macht natürlich auch spaß
und ich wollte einfach mal wissen ob ihr
darauf lust habt ob ihr auch dann legen
wir die zeit hab jedes video zuschauer
doch gesagt hey das ist zuviel keine
ahnung und wenn ihr bock drauf habt dann
schreibst du auf jeden fall meine
kommentare das jetzt schon mal einen
fetten daumen nach oben da dann sehe ich
das hier anhand der rezension
und ja jetzt viel spaß mit dem video ist
so im block stil gehalten aber bestimmt
ganz cool
also viel spaß jetzt kommt der christ
anfang an kaputt gegangen und herzlich
willkommen das kann nicht sein
weil mein video ja leute schöne grüße
aus hamburg ich bin gerade in hamburg
und das ding ist immer wenn ich in
hamburg - schlechtes wetter schaut euch
einfach mal das wetter an er werde jetzt
mittlerweile schon 12 uhr und im
eigentlich wollte schon längst in der
stadt seien nur es regnet und sowie die
da unten will ich jetzt eigentlich nicht
rumlaufen ich meine hamburg ist wirklich
so eine schöne stadt und da will man ja
auch irgendwie was von seen mit schönem
wetter aber irgendwie macht mir das
wetter wieder einen strich durch die
rechnung egal wir kommen zum thema habe
mich eigentlich diesen block war okay
wir machen natürlich erstmal noch eine
kurze tour wir haben hier ein
wunderschönes bett da haben wir ein ganz
tolles sofa ein fernseher der aussieht
wie deren im krankenhaus hier habe ich
eine xxl minibar mit einem wasser drin
da gibt's kaffee hier ist ein
wunderschöner spiegel
wir eine wunderschöne dusche und dann
noch zu hause ok deutschland nicht so
dass jetzt das war wirklich sehr sehr
schönes licht um das ein oder andere
spiegelzelt zu machen ja das wetter ist
zwar scheiße aber ich muss trotzdem in
die stadt gehen gar nicht allein in
hamburg marie ist auch dabei falls sich
die kennen und zwar gehen wir heute ein
bisschen shoppen das ding ist
ich habe gestern eine kleine wette
verloren zwar haben wir gewartet wie
weit hamburg von köln entfernt ist
ich hab gesagt die haben maximal drei
stunden es waren dann doch film und ich
war mir wirklich so sicher das ist nicht
so weit ist und hab gesagt ihr habt was
auf wenn wir nicht in drei stunden da
sind also das ding wir sind wegen mir
extra ein bisschen später losgefahren
und ich habe gesagt ja kommen wir sind
in drei stunden
sie meinten ein und dann haben wir
irgendwie so gewettet und dann kam raus
wenn wir halt nicht in drei stimmen da
sind dass ich dann alles was sie sich
hier kaufen möchte jetzt vielleicht noch
mal ein kleiner nachtrag damit die das
versteht also wir waren wegen mir halt
echt mega spät dran und haben deswegen
halt zu drei stunden hamburg verlor
ich habe dann gesagt da kommen dann geht
halt einfach ganz auf mich so nach dem
motto war aber auch ganz witzig und auch
den fall ab dass verdienen dass ich
alles sondern das ist wirklich was würde
sagen wir gehen jetzt gleich mal los ich
bin gespannt
ich war auch schon jetzt wieder ein
halbes jahr nicht mehr hier nicht zwei
monaten verletzt bis gleich
und ich finde das heute mal mit so einer
drexler ja auch wenn ich die schon
bislang nicht mehr benutzt habe macht es
spaß so leute kommen der aufzug ist so
cool marie ist jetzt auch dabei was geht
hier ist einfach blaues schlechthin
das wetter ist einfach so es ist so
krass anregt wir fahren jetzt im auto
ich musste das auto ungefähr einen
halben kilometer weg parken weil in
diesem parkhaus vom hotel kein platz
mehr war
ja auf jeden fall gut mit ich habe nicht
mal nicht mal 20 stunden gepaart mit 25
euro zahlen
dies ist ein parkplatz
danke mann
was ist das gerät wieder auf mich
planungsrecht im regen ja es ist so
heftig am regnen all diese qualität des
bombastisch von der kamera wenn man es
eigentlich ein park machen
während rennen liegend parkplatz
gefunden und wir fahren jetzt erst mal
die altstadt und wir hoffen dass der
regen gleich aus setzt aber wir werden
sehen
übrigens du musst mehr auf mich will
weil man sieht mich kaum herbie mann ist
das wohnhaus beschuldigung mein fehler
[Musik]
so ich muss jetzt erstmal zu tommy
hilfiger mir eine neue winterjacke
kaufen für 400 euro
leute was ein wundervoller
weihnachtsbaum auf jeden fall gehen wir
jetzt noch zusätzlich habe der winter
ecke gesehen die hat 400 euro gekostet
und ich wollte mir keine winter holen
für 400 euro
ich habe für mich heute einfach noch gar
nichts gefunden also keine jacke keine
schule keine hose nur 18 jahre
herausgegeben für sie
[Musik]
das so
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da jetzt mal diesen pulli kann man mal
nehmen irgendwie doch nur wenig mit dir
ich habe ohne spaß noch nichts gefunden
gar nichts nicht mal in unterhose
forscher ist in den laden könne man
nicht gehen er ist gelöst
ja ich will ja noch schöner wenn
vergeben müsste auf die andere seite
ich war das schon mal drin in dem genau
in dem
leute ich habe gerade den größten snipes
einkauf meines lebens gemacht hat eine
richtig geile gefunden ich habe richtig
ins spiel gefunden
also das war plötzlich alles auf einmal
sogar richtig vieles gefallen und auch
einen richtig geilen pullover und jetzt
habe ich sogar für mich bezahlt
das heißt du nochmal stürmern und das
brauchst du noch ein handy das war's
[Musik]
jetzt kommt es noch diese hause fahren
wir glaube ich war 15 stunden gerecht
ist jeder wieder und zeigt noch habe ich
so viel ausgeben
sieht man mich überhaupt ja so nämlich
gut ich kann mich nicht auf das navi das
leben
wir sind jetzt fertig endlich ich bin
auch tot gefühlt
ja hab ich krieg beim shop mit mal so
einen langen rechts appelliert sie
keinen job mann war so ein gefühl der
langeweile und das haben wir gerade
wieder erreicht ich muss meine richtung
gerade ja egal wie wir film gleich
weiter wartet man das auch könnte immer
filme wie findest du das was uns am
coolsten wer will das wissen
[Gelächter]
sieht echt schön aus tutorials du dir
ausgesucht sondern jetzt muss er sagt
noch so knapp wie hier so wenn du bist
so leute werden jetzt schon sonntag
gestern war es ein bisschen doch ich
weiß nicht aber noch kurz ich bin
richtig stolz auf meine schulter guckt
euch mal diese schuhe an
die sind echt cool die habe ich ganz
durch zufall gefunden und habe mich dann
sofort zugeschlagen
und dann habe ich mir noch eine richtig
geile geholt heute schaut euch machen
wollen schaut euch mal diese jacke hier
an
ich finde das nicht richtig cooler und
das coole ist erstens dies waren und
zwei ins rutschen
man kann die elf raum man kann ich
einfach auch noch auf die andere seite
ziehen und dann ist ja echt bomben war
also eine gelbe jacke ist ganz witzig
aus eigentlich da kommt mein bizeps
plastinieren da kommt ein witz minion ja
du meinst also doch mehr geld
da kommt mein bizeps auf jeden fall
ziemlich dort zum vorschein
und dann habe ich hier noch für den juli
daten nämlich geburtstag wurde ein pulli
gekauft von snipes den täter aber also
es geht in dem bevor das video online
kommt ich finde meine kommentare
schreiben wir den pulli findet oder
führte den kurs nach oben da was hier
noch kurz sagen wollte des mini kamera
geben egal wir sehen uns einfach gleich
im auto
wirklich verlosung hey was hat das mit
meinem youtube-video zu tun
leute das geht jetzt auf jeden fall nach
köln wieder und java schön hier in
hamburg so leicht etwas geht
wir haben jetzt gerade montag ich bin
gerade aufgestanden ich muss jetzt
vielleicht auch los und meinen pflichten
nachgehen hier in köln auf jeden fall
habe ich im auto vergessen das video zu
ende zu führen ich habe mir übrigens
eine hose gekauft ich habe mich jetzt
allerdings bei meinen eltern zu hause
vergessen weil ich da jetzt auch noch
war die ist auch echt cool aber ihr habt
eigentlich fast alles im video gesehen
ja ich hoffe diese schuhe also guckt
euch das mal an ich habe mir gestern mal
den vorgestern gekauft habe so ein spray
dazu geholt weil meine weißen schuhe
werden echte mal richtig schnell dreckig
und ich will erst mal gespannt ob das
was hilft weil die kann das ja bestimmt
auch wenn man in irgendwelchen schule in
was einkauft so foot locker stripes oder
so die wollen haben wir noch so ein
spray andrehen
ich dachte aber bis jetzt immer das
hilft eh nicht und es einfach nur
geldmacherei
aber ich habe das mal aufgetragen ich
bin gespannt das lustige war ich kann so
gestern mit diesen schuhen zu meinen
eltern eine firma künftig so die schuhe
an freiheit mich so was planst du denn
für mondlandung war ganz lustig auf
jeden fall so viel zu diesem video ich
hoffe natürlich jetzt hat euch gefallen
wie ich ja noch anfang gesagt im
dezember jeden tag ein video wäre
natürlich krass ich habe richtig bock
drauf und ihr könnt ja mal daumen nach
oben geben oder das in die kommentare
schreiben wenn ihr auch begriff habe
ansonsten sehen wir uns am mittwoch
wieder videos kommen jetzt er immer um
15 uhr ja und ich wünsche euch noch
einen ganz schönen tag hart nein